on May 21st I weighed one hundred and
ninety eight point three pounds fast
forward one month later on June 21st
which is today as a filming I weighed
one hundred and seventy nine point eight
pounds in one month I lost 19 and a half
pounds I'm gonna share with you the
seven ways that I did it so growing up I
never had to worry about my weight I was
always a pretty skinny kid I was 6 1
I weighed 165 pounds at the lower level
of just barely being healthy according
those BMI charts and so I could eat
whatever I want pretty active kid but
then growing up as you get into your 30s
you know the weight starts adding up
especially for entrepreneurs living a
busy lifestyle and I quickly found
myself to being almost 200 pounds and so
I decided I got to get my act together I
got to lose some weight some of you guys
have been commentating a notice saying
thank you for the love and so in today's
video I'm gonna share with you the seven
ways that I use to lose nineteen and a
half pounds in one month
[Music]
so way number one is I would fast until
noon and fasten for me would be liquids
only and really that's just water lots
of water here and coffee now this
probably wasn't the healthiest part I
would have two of these that would last
me from whenever I woke up usually
around seven ish until twelve o'clock
one o'clock and this is an extra-large
to milk one sugar from Tim Hortons so
having two extra-large coffees probably
wasn't the healthiest choice in the
morning but I found that one the
caffeine really helped curb the appetite
and I found if I delayed my eating until
the afternoon then I could consume the
calories that I needed in the afternoon
and not get started too early I found
when I started eating too early then
that I just kept eating all day long and
I found it difficult to kind of stay on
the diet its 11:55
decisions what have I got a hoarder what
am I gonna eat and so fast into noon
only water and coffee and then we eat my
first meal at noon at the earliest
sometimes one or even 1:30 wait number
two is 30 minutes of cardio everyday
what I found the easiest thing to do was
actually just at night at 9 o'clock I
would set a routine that my wife and I
would usually watch something on TV some
show we'd watch arrow or billions or
what else we watch arrow billions from
Gotham blind spot we mix between the
shows we sit down at 9 9 o'clock and I
would run on the spot
at 9 o'clock so it'd just be like while
we're watching the show I'd be like this
I'd be running running running for half
an hour after that I do some stretching
and usually those shows with no
commercials go about 40 ish minutes 42
minutes so it's the perfect time so I
knew 9 o'clock watch the show half an
hour running 10 to 12 minutes of
stretching afterwards it was the perfect
setting and then have a shower and get
ready for bed I've seen suggesting it
just recently where I do a morning run
instead I usually run to the local Whole
Foods that's about 15 minutes away then
pick up a kombucha some salad bananas
maybe and come back but for most of that
weight loss journey it was a nine
o'clock 30-minute run and I did that
every single day of the week we number
three is I use a Seinfeld technique and
the Seinfeld technique is to print a
calendar for the year so here's mine my
calendar for the year I'm basically
every single day you want to mark it off
with an X on the calendar when you've
done that thing and so for me the two
things I was tracking was running 30
minutes a day and fast until noon if I
did that I would get an X and so the
goal is to not break the chain and so
every single day I would get my X and
you can see here I started it this just
before my May 21st date so May 21st is
what here somewhere and up until June
21st which is today it's not quite noon
filming this yet so I can't mark it off
but that really helped just kind of stay
on track and you'd like to see the
progress and when you see those X's
coming on you don't want to break the
chain so you want to keep going every
day we number four would say you
saturday is a cheat day and that was
when I could eat whatever I wanted you
know there was no calorie restrictions I
just ate ate ate ate ate ate ate but I
still had to keep my chain so I still
was running for 30 minutes in the day
and I was still fasting until noon this
was one of the hardest things because I
get this delicious doughnut from Tim
Hortons or this breakfast that ends at
noon and so I really wanted to eat that
so he buy it a couple minutes early I'd
be sitting there looking at my doughnut
like I got five minutes left before I
can eat this thing
and then once noon came look show it in
so Saturday is my cheat day but I still
am on my fast until noon it's 15 minutes
till noon and I'm excited to dig into my
Boston cream doing it this is gonna be a
brutal 15 minutes I love it so that
really helped that helps it helps on a
psychological level to have one day when
you can eat whatever you want and I
think there is also a lot of research
that backs up having a cheat day to kind
of spike your levels and then come back
down can actually facilitate more weight
loss as well and so I found that really
helpful but I kept to my fashion until
noon and running 30 minutes a day guys
when you persevere and it's hard and you
make it through and you win the victory
is just so much sweeter we number five
was no packaged foods and so I made a
decision apart from the coffee that
would have in the morning I wouldn't eat
anything from a package so nothing with
a wrapper nothing store-bought that was
not just processed but even healthy
stuff I wouldn't eat from a wrapper so
we need protein bars before and just
other things from packaged and decided
nope not gonna do it anymore
and most of my diet consists of fish we
don't really eat a lot of meat except on
Saturdays just fish and vegetables fish
vegetables nuts
mostly assortment of whitefish Cod
different filets haddock walleye bunch
of stuff Nina's been fantastic in
helping kind of
caryl the foods and it's great having a
partner on this journey so she's eaten
basically the same stuff I am
and then broccoli and cabbage and green
beans and sugar snap peas and it's
basically pretty easy to get filled up
because you're only really even two big
meals a day I would start usually at
noon eating a banana
- bananas probably two bananas sometimes
three bananas in the day and then into
my lunch and then into my dinner and
that would be it
I would snack on nuts and everything
basically not from a package trying to
trying to say healthy stratus a clean
and it's really helped with the weight
loss way number six is used My Fitness
Pal My Fitness Pal is an app that allows
you to track your calories and I'll load
it up here to show you guys so what you
can do is put in the foods can you see
can you see can you see anyway what you
can do is you they have goals this is a
free app that's put up by Under Armor I
think it's under armour you can put in
your goals of how high you are how like
how how high you are you pick how tall
you are what your goal is for weight and
how quickly you want to achieve it and
it'll give you a calorie target and then
you can enter in your food and it gives
you a sense of what every single meal
looks like and so if you're eating an
avocado you might think that's really
healthy but has a lot of calories and so
just being able to balance it out if you
are educated to know what is in your
food there are days that I will go to I
will go to Tim Hortons and get a crispy
chicken sandwich which is fried chicken
and bread and you know fairly high
calories like 540 calories something
like that but it fits it fits within my
day and so just educating yourself on
how many calories are in each meal is
great it has a barcode scanners so if
you are eating out then you can easily
find most of the foods that the major
chains if you are anything from a
package you can barcode scan it and
it'll tell you the nutritional breakdown
on it and it'll tell you how much you
should be eating in terms of protein fat
and carbohydrates and then you can see
am i matching up I think the biggest
thing for me was just recognizing the
difference in the foods and educating
myself so I could eat more appropriately
and match my intake to where I should be
and so why we do a lot of fish
is because it's insanely high protein to
get your protein targets easily and not
a lot of calories and so if you're
eating that it's a lot easier to fill up
your day with other stuff that you want
to eat because you're hitting your
targets at a really low calorie level so
I would highly recommend checking out my
Fitness Pal free-to-use
and there's a premium program that you
can upgrade to I don't use it but you
can and it'll help you on your journey
[Music]
and we number seven this is the most
recent thing that I'm doing I'm trying
to substitute out coffee for kombucha
and so kombucha is supposed to be super
healthy full of probiotics got some got
a whole bunch of stuff floating around
in it and I do my morning run to Whole
Foods pick up a kombucha I am now
between one kombucha and no coffees two
to one coffee a day and I'm slowly
starting to substitute at the coffee cup
or kombucha during the week the coffee
is the only thing really in my diet
apart from Saturday that that is junkie
that is not healthy that is from a box
that is packaged and so I want to slowly
reduce that and replace it with the
kombucha and then on weekend Saturday
Saturday only eat whatever I want and so
those are the seven things that's really
helped me on my weight-loss journey
again at the beginning I never thought I
had to worry about it growing up was
always super skinny and always healthy
and at some point life catches up with
you and you got to decide to invest in
yourself and and be healthy so those are
the things I did I would love to hear
from you which one had the biggest
impact on you which one might shift your
perspective I would love for you to
share your story as well and if I miss
an 8 9 10 that you want to add to the
list that has helped you please put in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're on where it is much
love I'll see you soon
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a whale out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder engine
now you know I'm bad over the last week
I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access